rocky is introducing us to a
local company a man who has a local
company says where he comes from
air conditioning is a luxury well as we
know here in las vegas
it is an absolute necessity his company
is dedicated to making sure
everyone in our community can afford
cool and clean air
carlos ava maria of buenos aires air
conditioning and heating why did you
decide to bring this business to vegas
well it's been a long time dream of mine
i i migrated to this country when i was
12.
and then a vocational school offered
certain uh
certain things and or different traits
and i picked air conditioning and then
after that i went to
university got a degree in air
conditioning and kept
learning and learning and learning the
age of 24 is when i started when ocitis
air conditioning
incredible and it's been nothing but a
success so carlos what does buenos aires
specialize in
what do you guys provide we provide
service for the residential
aspect of things and we do
maintenances service and installations
we can do anything with with the air
conditioner we could also do air quality
for the homes filtration system
ultraviolet lights
for all things are going on uh so we we
do a lot of air quality
and we do a units replacements
maintenance of your equipment
and also service how is the the current
pandemic in covet 19 affecting the
industry and
in particularly your company well in
many ways
it's it's affected in many ways there's
more training involved right
um there's more uh things that we have
to purchase obviously you know to
protect ourselves
um and and and take all the precautions
it's slowing a little bit down in the
aspect of the operations of the business
in regards to the equipment um there is
a uh
it's effectiveness in a way that we
weren't foreseen you know the equipment
is
even though it's built here in the
states uh there is some some parts that
they might grab from other places
uh other countries okay and these
countries are going through what we went
through three four months ago
everything's shut down
so uh right now the uh the parts are are
scarce they're not that many of them
therefore there are some shortages some
surges of units
and and to prevent that ourselves what
we do is uh
we try to keep our shop stocked okay
with with different type of
sizes of equipment because it's not just
one air conditioner right right
so we try to keep a little bit of
everything so we make sure that our
customers are taken care of
or new customers are taken care of so in
that aspect
yes we have been affected in regards to
the production of the equipment that we
provide to our customers
if it happens to where one unit it just
cannot be found
what we do is we actually put a loaner
on the home okay until it arrives after
it's been manufactured
i know that you guys also specialize in
making these ac units affordable because
this can get expensive yeah it sure can
actually the air conditioner
is the most expensive appliance of your
home we have uh we
have very competitive prices and at the
same time we have very
good financing options for people with
great credit with poor credit
uh very very low payments that's the way
how we can help
our community be able to obtain the most
expensive appliance in their home
we're definitely looking after our
clients to make sure they can afford
this expenditure
well you can learn more about buenos
aires air conditioning and heating by
calling that phone number 702-794-2727
they do offer special financing
for new units and filters